[MUSIC PLAYING]
MYOSHA MCAFEE: So
I'm Myosha McAfee.
I've been at Google for about
10 months, 10 and a half,
maybe I'm at that 11th mark.
I'm not sure yet.
And I'm a principal
racial equitect.
Yes, I made that title up.
I love Google because I
get to make up my titles.
And that essentially means I'm
trained as a social scientist,
a race scholar.
And I am responsible
for figuring
out how do we grapple with
race and its intersections
as a company?
And really thinking
about what does it
look like in the workplace
in a corporation,
even though it's Googley
type of corporation.
And I'm very excited to be
a part of Decoding Race.
This is the seventh
in a 12 part series.
And we wanted to center on
intersectionality today.
Talk about being
more than a woman,
the intersection of race,
gender, and sexual orientation.
And so I want to first
welcome our guests here,
distinguished guests.
And thank you, Austin,
for having us here.
First up we have television
and fashion personality,
EJ Johnson, let's give him
a warm round of welcome.
Next to EJ is Tanzina Veiga.
Tanzina is a national
reporter for "CNN Money,"
where she covers issues of
race inequality in America.
Prior to working at CNN,
Vega was a staff reporter
for "The New York Times,"
where she created a beat--
she created a beat--
covering issues of
race and ethnicity
for the National Desk.
And it's important to
note, she created a beat.
[APPLAUSE]
Next to Tanzina is
Dr. Kim Crenshaw.
Woo.
She's a Professor of Law at
UCLA and Columbia Law School,
and a leading scholar in
civil rights, black feminism,
and the law.
She actually coined two terms
that have become essential
in our conversations about race
and its intersections, critical
race theory, if
you've ever heard
of it, and intersectionality.
If you're using those words,
she created those words.
Let's give it up
for Dr. Crenshaw.
[APPLAUSE]
Next to her is Linda Sarsour,
is a Palestinian-American
Muslim scholar, activist,
and media commentator.
She is the Executive Director
of the Arab American Association
of New York, co-founder of the
first Muslim online organizing
platform, Empower Change, and
the co-chair and organizer
of the Women's March in DC.
[APPLAUSE]
So we have some serious,
serious people upfront.
We want to get real
honest, real raw.
We want to speak our
truths, and we're
hoping that you can bear
witness to this space,
find your own story
in it, and if not,
just hold space with
somebody else's reality here.
First up, we're going to just
start with a big ol' word
intersectionality, and
just break it down.
So we're going to start out
with Kim just breaking it down
for us.
Because this form was born
out of the late essayist Audre
Lorde's, "there is no such thing
as a single issue struggle,
because we do not live
single issue lives."
It centers intersectionality.
It's an idea you
introduced and developed,
so let's begin with a
simple breakdown of what
is intersectionality,
how do you define it,
why should we be
talking about it?
KIM CRENSHAW: All right.
So I'll give the
elevator version
and offer some illustrations.
The elevator version
basically is this--
intersectionality
reflects the reality
that systems of subordination--
power, discrimination,
like racism, sexism,
heterosexism, ableism--
are not separate and distinct
forms of discrimination.
Many times they overlap.
They interlock.
They create kinds of
problems and challenges
that can't be addressed if you
think of these issues as just
single issues.
So it's the simple
fact that, if you just
experience race
discrimination as a woman,
you're probably experiencing
both race and gender
discrimination.
And so the simple
version is just
recognizing that there
are multiple forms
of discrimination.
Some people are subject
to more than one of them,
and if your tools that you
have to identify and intervene
do not focus on
the intersections,
you're probably not doing
much to alleviate the problem.
Now that's the elevator version.
Here is a more, I guess,
narrative version.
Intersectionality
was basically a term
that I used to try
to explain a problem.
It was a problem in a workforce.
It was a problem
with black women
who were basically saying that
in the industry that they were
in, it was the
auto manufacturing
industry, that they were
being discriminated against.
They couldn't get hired.
The problem was
that the courts had
a version of what race
discrimination looked like
and it was what
happened to black men.
And they had a
version of what gender
discrimination looked
like, and it was
what happened to white women.
These black women
were saying, well,
what happens to
white women and what
happens to black men
doesn't really tell you much
about what's happening to us.
So white women, yes,
they are experiencing
a form of discrimination here.
They can't work in any other
place in this industry but as
a secretary or a receptionist
or a telephone operator.
The way they experience
gender discrimination
isn't exactly the same way
that we're experiencing
gender discrimination.
They have to work
as secretaries.
We can't work at all.
Or they'll say
African-American men are
experiencing discrimination.
When they apply here at this
auto manufacturing plant,
they're only allowed to work
in the front, on the floor,
in the heavy jobs, in
the dangerous jobs.
That's discrimination.
But their discrimination
is not the same as ours,
because as women, we
can't even get that work.
So the point of
intersectionality
was to say, we can
figure this out
if we just use a real common
metaphor, an intersection.
So some part of the way that
workforce was structured,
the roads, was a
racial structure.
Black jobs are here.
White jobs are here.
The other part of the structure
was a gender structure.
Women can work here.
Women cannot work here.
If you are a black
person who is a woman,
you are actually
situated where those two
policies come together.
So the traffic, the policy,
the hiring decisions
that go down the race road
or the gender road actually
creates an intersection
where those people who
are black and female are
subject to discrimination.
So it's not really
a complicated idea,
but it is one that
requires people
to understand that
intersectionality is not
just about identity.
It's about identity in a context
in which your identity makes
a difference in your
access to equality
or your availability
to discrimination.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: All right.
So we're going to drill
down a little bit more
to talk about this
because we want
to move into our
lived experience,
not just in the words that kind
of float up here at 50,000 feet
high level abstract.
So I want to start
out with you, Linda,
just talking about
how do you actually,
how are you living your
intersectional life?
What are points,
what are contexts
where you experience
advantages and the context
where you're experiencing
disadvantages?
LINDA SARSOUR: Thank you so
much for having me here today.
I came here from
Brooklyn, New York.
So I bring a lot.
No, I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
I think to Dr. Crenshaw's
point and Aydre Lorde,
I mean it's just so simple,
but yet so profound.
You know I'm Palestinian.
I come from a heritage and
a lineage of people living
under military occupation.
My parents came here
to live a better life.
I'm a woman.
I'm a woman of color.
I'm an activist, a
political activist.
I'm a parent.
I'm a young mom, had my first
kid when I was 17 years old.
So I bring a lot to the table.
And I want to be treated
as a whole person.
And my lived experience as
someone who's a Muslim woman
is that there have been people
who, just the minute they
see me, they have already
preconceived what my story is
and how I got to where I got to.
And I think that,
and I'll give you
an example of what
intersectionality, how
it actually plays out.
Because again, it's
not complicated.
But it requires work.
So I was one of the
co-chairs of the Women's
March on Washington.
And originally it started
as the women's rights
are human rights, right?
And it started the
first three days
by well-intentioned
white women who
were like women's
rights are human rights
and reproductive rights and
Planned Parenthood and all
this stuff.
And when women of color
came to the table,
we were like, hold
on a second here, no.
We can't go to
the table as women
and talk about
reproductive rights
and leave out every
other issue that
needs to be brought
to the table because
as an Arab-American Muslim
woman, a Chicano Mexican
woman, Carmen Perez and
me, we were like, no, no.
You can't talk about
women's reproductive rights
without talking about
race and class and access.
You can't talk about
women's reproductive rights
without talking about race
or about racial justice
and criminal justice.
And if we win justice, and we
don't have a planet to live on,
like it just all
kind of intersects.
So people thought it was great,
and you got to the march,
and it was like
oh, so inspiring.
But in fact, the
process getting there
was not that inspiring
often, because it required
us being able to say
that we are whole people,
and we come from mixed--
I come from a mixed
status family.
I have people in my family
who are undocumented.
I've got to talk
about them, too.
I come from the racial
justice movement.
And I want to talk, I
want to say her name.
You know, I want to be
able to say Black Lives
Matter on the stage, and
being able to teach people
that we have enough of a big
heart and enough of intellect
for me to be able to say
Black Lives Matter, justice
for immigrants, justice
for LGBTQI people,
religious freedom,
whatever, all together, like
we could do that.
And that's for me what
intersectionality is at play,
that we welcome people
with all their complexities
to the table.
We don't allow people to
leave any part of them
out because it's not convenient
for the work or the movement
or for quote 'social
justice' that everyone comes
to the table within everything.
If you don't accept all of me as
an intersectional human being,
then that's not the space
that I want to be in.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Thank you.
We want to keep it personal,
local, and immediate.
Tanzina, you want
to step in, talk
about how you're living
an intersectional life.
TANZINA VEGA: So my
intersectionality, I guess,
would be described as I'm a
Puerto Rican woman, Latina,
but specifically
Puerto Rican I think.
And I say that because the
conversations around Latinos
today I think are very narrow
in the way we look at it.
Everybody's an immigrant.
Everybody's a Mexican.
Everybody just got here.
That's not the case.
In many cases it is,
and I have the numbers
if you want to dig
deeper into that,
but I'd like to also
showcase that there
are different types of
Latinidad, is what we call it.
And so by definition that
makes me racially a very
mixed and diverse person.
There are black
people in my family,
there are people who have Taino
blood, which is the Indians who
were on the island
of Puerto Rico,
and obviously there's white
European blood there as well.
Which is why I am sort of
ambiguously ethnic to a lot
of people when they see me.
They know I'm not white,
but they know I'm not black.
Actually I had a
student in South Korea
once say to me, when I
was teaching ESL there,
said teacher, you're not
white, you're not black.
What are you?
And I was like, that's another
two hours that we get to kill.
But it was a poignant question.
I mean we're in this
tiny town in South Korea.
This was in 2002.
And so they didn't
have a lot of exposure
to anything other
than mainstream media.
And mainstream media, as someone
that works in the mainstream
media now, that
wasn't always the path
that I thought I
was going to be on.
And the images that we get
of who we are from mainstream
media, for me growing
up as a Latina,
as a Puerto Rican woman,
but also as a working
class and poor family.
I lived in public housing
for the first 20, 21
years of my life.
So right there, if I say,
I grew up in the projects.
Think about what's in
your mind right now, what
you're imagining.
If I hadn't said
that, and I just
sat here and said "New
York Times," CNN, traveled
the world, taught in South
Korea, like your image of me
is very different probably
than what you have in your mind
right now if I say I spent 21
years in the projects, right?
Now it's like, oh, OK,
that's a change, right?
But that's a core identity.
That's a core part of who I am.
But also in the conversations
around intersectionality,
we often forget about class.
I think class is one of the
most underrepresented parts
of the conversation, and
an area that so many of us
can connect on and we
tend to not do that.
And I say, and of
course, I'm a woman.
I'm a heterosexual woman so
that presents its own set
of challenges in many cases.
And I'm a woman of a certain
age, I won't say where,
but probably a little
older than a couple of you.
And so all of these
things are connected,
and none of these things.
But yet growing up,
there was never really
a space for people like me.
And when Kim and I were
talking before we got here,
I said one of my goals
is to really start
to create more spaces--
oops, sorry, there's my water--
where people who were
living these sorts
of intersectional lives can
come together, where you see
yourself reflected.
So I said I grew
up in the projects.
Everybody probably has an image
of what that looks like, right?
Well, guess what?
There are also people
in the projects who
work every day
and raise families
and aren't drug addicted
or any other thing.
But there are lots
of pathologies that
also happen in public housing.
So being able to survive
that was one thing,
but being able to also not get
involved in that lifestyle,
you didn't really
feel like I fit there.
But I didn't necessarily
fit in certain other areas.
And when it came to being a
feminist, which I define myself
as, that was also something
that was like, whoa,
this is a really
white conversation
that really tends to be
led by white wealthy,
or women of means, educated
white women of means.
So while I believed in
a lot of the tenets,
I felt like that conversation
was very limited.
And it did not
embrace the totality
of who I am as a
person, of what I
have to deal with as a woman
of color, of what I have
to deal with as a woman who
came from a working class
background.
And so there are so many of--
and believe me, I traveled the
world for four years on my own.
There weren't a lot of people
that looked like me out there.
This whole backpacking thing?
That was a very white thing
to do back in the day.
Everybody was like what do you--
what?
You don't even know
anybody in China?
No, but I'm out.
And then even being in
China was like what?
Like you're not blond?
People who just didn't get it.
And I mean, it was an
amazing experience.
But it also shows
the limitations
to how we as Americans
define who we are and really
take into account the different
layers that each of us has.
And all of those things, how am
I living my intersectionality,
well, I'm living it by doing it.
If any of you follow
me on Twitter,
I'm very vocal about
issues of diversity,
particularly in the industry
that I work in, which is media.
But I also created
content around this issue.
And whether it's media
representation or inequality,
that's my contribution to it.
But it comes from a place of
real experience and personal
and lived experience.
So I hope that
answered your question.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Yeah.
It's Your story.
You tell it how you
want to tell it.
TANZINA VEGA: And I could go on.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: All
right, EJ, [INAUDIBLE]
us a personal look [INAUDIBLE].
EJ JOHNSON: Yeah, well, I will
say that my personal experience
is just a lot of ups and downs.
A lot of almost
contradictions really.
I am a black male.
I'm part of the LGBTQ
community as well.
But also I had to learn about--
my struggles were different
from a lot of other people's
growing up, like not only do I
have to deal with black male,
but now, oh, my god, I'm gay.
What do I do?
So at the same time, I came
from a privileged family.
So I didn't necessarily have
to deal with the race card
the first thing on the table.
But you know, it's something
that my parents always
taught me, like this is what
our people went through.
This is what you
may face one day.
And eventually I had
to see that for myself.
And then growing up
and then finding out,
holy crap, I'm different
again, here I am being gay
and gender fluid.
So now what do I do?
So that was a whole
other experience for me.
And just because someone
might look at me,
and just, oh, well,
look at this queen go.
You have it all, or you're
wearing fancy clothes
and doing this and that.
But I have my own struggles.
And I think that that's
what the great thing
about this
intersectionality thing is
is just that we are all part of
so many different communities,
and they come together in
ways that might be daunting
and but at the same
time are also beautiful.
But I think that the thing is
it's so hard to not put people
in boxes and just look at
one struggle or one thing
that somebody else is doing.
You have to look at everything.
And a lot of the times that
person has to tell you,
and you have to just
really listen to them
and listen to their stories
and listen to their struggles
to understand what's going
on in their mind, what's
going on in their life.
And that's really where
I think that we're
getting rid of that
kind of discrimination.
We're really listening
to and looking
at all the different sections
that that person is in.
And for me personally,
it was just
a lot of ups and downs for me.
I thought, OK, I'm not really
dealing with this race thing,
but now people are staring
because of the way I dress.
People are staring
because I'm holding hands
with some other boy.
People are making comments
or snickering to me
and talking to me
on social media.
And there's just
so much pressure.
And especially after I
had a public coming out,
which most people don't
have to deal with.
That's really when you
know the red flags raised
for me, that I have to be here.
I have to stand my ground,
because not everyone's
going to have my back.
And I tried not to read a lot
of the things that people wrote
about me or said,
but at the same time,
it cannot be ignored.
And of course, it stemmed
from a lot of ignorance
and a lot of hate.
But I just had to stay
true to who I was.
I wasn't changing.
And I'm never going to not be
me just because some sad woman
in her basement--
[LAUGHTER]
--wants to come for me.
But the point is it
was a lot to deal
with at the time, because I
was still relatively young.
And at the same time, I
just had to understand
where that type of
ignorance was coming from.
And that for the time being,
it's not going to change.
That people can be
nice to your face
and people can give you hugs
and be like oh yes, yes, yes.
But you don't really
know what they're
going home and saying about
you or what they're doing.
And you have to really
do that extra work
to make sure that those people
know that they can't break you
down, and also, too, you bring
all your communities together
and uplift that type of
hatred, because that's
where we're kind of
moving but we need
to keep that momentum going.
Because it's going
to be extremely
important for the future.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Thank you.
So now I want to go back to
the organizing of the Women's
March.
And you were like at the
end there was some glory,
but on the way there
were some challenges.
LINDA SARSOUR: There's
not a lot of glory.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: I
think when we're
trying to figure out how
do we design solutions
or how do I as an
individual, I as a team,
begin to actually apply
intersectional frameworks.
And one thing that I
think is a common practice
that we grapple with here is
as soon as we start centering
marginalized communities,
whether that's
black folks or queer
folks or poor folks,
people of the more privileged
class start looking
for the side of their identity
that has disadvantage,
and like what about this?
Why can't this be at the center?
So I'll give one example.
We want to talk about race.
There are people like
let's talk about gender.
And it's a constant like,
let's make this a single issue.
Let's put them in
competition with each other.
And so I'm curious
about what it'd
mean to have a march that
started out with white women
as organizers.
I know there was an incredible
amount of conversation
about where the women of
color, were women of color
even going to attend this event.
But once you guys all
decided to come on board,
what was the conversation?
Like how did the
agenda have to shift,
how did certain
practices have to shift,
what did white
women in particular,
what new role did they have
to take on, what new frame
works did they have to walk in,
and then women of color, what
was their difference that
they had to engage with?
LINDA SARSOUR: So when the
Women's March on Washington
was originally announced, it
was the Million Women's March.
And we were like,
educational moment.
There was already a
Million Women's March.
And I will say this in
just a little credit
to those particular white
women is that they really
didn't know, they had no idea.
So they changed the name, and
we went to the Women's March
on Washington,
with the blessings
of Bernice King, who's Dr.
Martin Luther King's daughter.
There was always conversations
that were happening even
when we took on that name.
And the skepticism that was
coming from women of color
was welcomed, because we were
the skeptical women of color,
too, that ended up
being part of the March.
But I will say this, we were
not about to allow white women
to have a national march
where they were going
to set the agenda for women
nationally and not have women
of color as part of
the conversation,
like we were just not
going let that happen.
So we took one for the team.
And what happened during
the organizing of the March
was that--
so I remember a "New
York Times" reporter
who wrote a story about
this where she was basically
trolling the Women's March
on Washington Facebook page.
And she saw a lot of
divisive, tense conversations
that were happening about why
we were talking about race
and why we were kind of
pushing this conversation.
And she asked this
question, and she said,
do you think this is
going to hurt the March?
Who is doing your social
media and whatever?
And I was like, hold up.
This is not an accident.
These conversations that
we're creating about race
are by design.
Like we were pushing those
conversations forward,
the way our social
media was talking
about the issues in an
intersectional manner
was designed that way.
And was it because we wanted
to create divisiveness?
That divisiveness had
nothing to do with us.
It had to do with the
people who were feeling
like there were some sort of--
they were offended by
something that they themselves
hadn't grappled with
as mostly white women.
So if I'm talking
to you about, you
want to talk about
pay equity, but you
don't want me to say you
may be a white woman not
getting the same pay as a man.
But black and Latino
and other women of color
are not getting paid
the same amount as you,
and you don't want me
to talk about that,
then you ain't
really in this forum.
And if you are offended
enough that you
don't want to come
to the March, I
think that March is going
to be just fine without you.
And then the other
conversation that
came up that was really
interesting in the way
that we think about
are we in this together
was a lot of controversy
around this idea why we didn't
like highlight Hillary Clinton.
Like why wasn't Hillary
Clinton like our poster
child for the Women's
March on Washington?
Clearly, I got 20
reasons why personally,
why she wasn't my
poster child, but I'll
leave that to the side.
But this idea that
people actually
thought that we would take a
privileged, multimillionaire
rich white lady that
has a dynasty to be
the face of the Women's March--
are you out of your mind is
my personal response to that.
But it was really a
lot of opportunities
to have what Carmen Perez
calls courageous conversations.
This is the reason why
we preach to the choir,
because we only want to
talk to people that only
agree with what we have to say.
And I say to women of
color and many of them
are people that I only mostly
organize with women of color
is that I get it.
I'm with you,
pain, trauma, we're
tired of having to
explain to white people
why they got to be in
the way that we want to,
but we are at a moment
right now in this country,
we're all in this together.
We're living under
fascism right now.
And in order for us to
defeat fascism or at least
survive under fascism, we've
got to be in this together.
So being able to take a little
extra time to be like, oh, OK.
What about this?
Read this.
Did you ever read this Book did
you read Dr. Kimberley's book?
Did you read that?
And for people to
actually say I will.
And that's the people
that we were working with.
People who genuinely just never
organize a day in their lives.
Like for example, Bob Bland, one
of the four national co-chairs
is a fashion entrepreneur.
That's what she
does for a living.
She don't really need to be an
activist, although I realize
that she was in her own way.
She does ethical manufacturing.
So her job is she incubates
fashion lines ethically
and within the United
States of America.
So I was like do you know that
that's a form of activism?
So in fact, there are women
who had different things
that they cared about that
they were able to bring.
One of them is a woman by
the name of Brianne Butler.
Brianne Butler was a baker.
She bakes cakes for a living.
Like the Women's March
was also an opportunity
to bring ordinary
people that are
not activists and in organizing
spaces and bringing them
to the table and saying
what talents do you have?
What do you care about?
How can we use you
to put this forth?
But at the end of
the day, what we
were able to do with the
Women's March on Washington,
inspired by longtime work
by people like Dr. Kimberly
is that it was an intersectional
march that was led by women.
It wasn't a women's march.
Because there were
men that were there,
and it was also an opportunity
for us to center to climate
justice, racial justice,
there were plenty
of black women on the stage.
And I didn't say this
earlier about myself.
So I'm a Palestinian
Muslim American.
I'm an Arab-American.
I'm white if you want to
be technical, according
to the US Census Bureau, right?
So I have light skin.
If I took this hijab off.
I'd be like any other
white lady in this room.
Darker hair, but I am white.
I mean, race wise.
So I chose as one of
the co-chairs to center
black Muslim woman in the March.
So for example, you
saw Alia Sharif,
she's a hip hop
artist from Oakland.
We had Muhammad Ali's daughter.
We had Sister Iesha
Prime from Baltimore.
Like I chose to use
my own privilege
as a light-skinned Muslim,
who may not have privilege
in the outside general society,
but within my own community,
let's be real.
I do get more platforms
than black Muslim women
do in my community.
So I chose at that moment
to be able to say, OK,
who am I centering
for my community here?
I'm going to center black
Muslim women voices.
And at the Women's March being
able to center trans voices
and center women of color
who are actually doing work
that is not necessarily
connected to being per se
a woman of color.
So for example, the
president of NRDC,
which is the National
Resource Defense Council,
is a black woman.
And she has dedicated her
life to climate justice,
for example.
Being able to also
take people and show
people that I don't have
to be a Muslim woman that
works on Muslim
issues, I could be
a Muslim woman running
a reproductive rights
organization.
I could be a Muslim woman
running a climate justice
organization.
So we did that.
And we were able to
center those voices,
and we were also
able to show people--
for example, like we
had no shame saying
to someone like
Scarlett Johansson,
you went over your time, and
you're getting your mic cut.
Like you don't get more time
than the undocumented Pakistani
girl from Staten Island.
The idea that we were able
to say, yes, and by the way,
FYI, you probably
don't know this.
We didn't invite those
celebrities just so you know.
Those were people
that came to us
and wanted to get down
with what we were doing.
So we didn't have to
go out and reach out.
The people we recruited were the
actual activists, organizers,
and directly impacted people
that were at the March.
So my point is that the
Women's March on Washington
wasn't all glory.
There was tense moments.
There were moments
where, believe it or not,
we were in intense conversations
where I remember clearly
where one woman said, a white
woman said, I'm feeling,
quote--
get ready for this one--
"I'm feeling like a
second class citizen."
Excuse me, do you
even understand
for you to be able to
say what it means to be--
I'm being marginalized
in this space.
Excuse me.
So being able to also allow
people to think and reflect
on the type of
language that they
use with people that
actually do fundamentally
understand marginalization.
People who
fundamentally understand
what it means to be a
second class citizen not
to say that women historically
haven't, white women included,
haven't felt like in certain
spaces as second class
citizens, but to be in a
space with women of color who
have had loved ones--
in our group-- loved ones die to
gun violence, police violence,
Carmen Perez's
sister, like people
who have been around gang
activity that has directly
impacted their
family, people who
understand state violence,
like in a very deep way,
have not gotten jobs because
of their race or other reasons,
for them to hear that,
it was triggering.
People were triggered.
And so there was a
lot of hard moments.
But what we ended up
manifesting at the Women's
March on Washington, and this
wasn't successful everywhere.
There were some states where
some of the people of color
were like, nah.
We ain't.
And we weren't
responsible for that,
because it was a decentralized
method of organizing, where
there were people
who individually took
the branding of the
Women's March on Washington
and made it their own.
We saw that as a first step.
But we did this in an
intersectional way.
We made sure that the agenda not
only gave women of color seats
at the table, but that the women
of color were on the table.
Like if you weren't
talking about us,
and we weren't at the
center of the conversation
as the most directly impacted
in this current environment,
we didn't want anything
to do with that.
But also being able to
see the power of centering
women of color, not just their
issues, but them as leaders.
So we came to the Women's March
on Washington, I was like look.
You ain't putting my cute
face as a token Muslim,
like that's just not happening.
I want to be a boss here.
And I want to have
a leadership role.
What do you want to do?
I want to fundraise, I
think that I'm good at that.
They were like, you
want to fundraise?
Yes, I want to fundraise.
And the reason why I
wanted to fundraise also
is because I wanted
to teach people
about being able to organize
a movement that is powered
by the people, which is
not a concept people often
to understand.
They always think we need to
have Wal-Mart in the back,
or even, to be honest,
even Google, right?
Even if you're a
corp like Patagonia,
there are some companies
that you may see and say
they're corporate responsible.
They're whatever, you
know what I'm saying.
And I said, guess what?
We could do this
without corporations.
I will not stand on a stage
that has Coca-Cola, or Pepsi
or any corporation behind me.
And white folks in
particular were really
like I don't think you're
going to be able to do that.
And we did it.
The March on Washington
was funded by the people--
by the $27, the $50,
the $20, the $10.
And it was also by the partners,
Planned Parenthood, MoveOn.org,
ACLU, and those type of folks
that came in and gave us
that money.
So being able to have
these hard conversations,
being able to be women of
color and say we will only
work under these
circumstances and being heard,
and that's why I want to give
the white women that we worked
with credit, because they
could have been like nah,
this is our, we
started this, that's
not how we envisioned it.
So you all need to step out.
We'll go find some other women
of color who aren't going to be
like y'all, and make us
do whatever we wanted.
And they were like no.
Maybe we're going to
learn something from you,
and maybe we are going
to do intersexual
and that's what happened
at the Women's March.
So I want all that to
say that I give credit
to those white
women who listened.
We actually said this to them.
Can you just listen
for a second?
So Tamika Mallory, who many
of you may know, is quite,
she got a little spice
in her, you know?
She's from the Bronx.
Like she's no joke, like
she puts it out there,
you take it or leave it.
And one day, she said,
do you know my story?
And when she shares that
her son's father was
shot and killed when her
son was only two years old,
found in a ditch two
weeks after he was dead,
and she had to witness that.
And her son's growing
up without his father,
living in a poor
community in the Bronx
and growing up in a civil
rights community and family
and has seen people
in her family arrested
and incarcerated, told
these very personal stories
about her family.
Then the women were like--
because you will never
experience what
Tamika Mallory has.
So don't ask her why
she's angry all the time.
She got reason to be angry.
And when Carmen tells
you that her sister was
buried on her 17th birthday.
So when it was
Carmen's 17th birthday,
her sister, who was
only two years older
was buried on her birthday
in Oxnard, California.
She grew up in a community
that was [INAUDIBLE] with gang
violence and poverty.
And when you hear
their stories, it
makes you sit back
and say whoa ho.
I'm never going to experience
what these ladies saw.
You know what?
I've got something
to learn from them.
So all that it required
was for women to sit back
not be defensive and
learn and listen,
and that's how we got to January
21st, which was up until today,
and I hope folks want
to do bigger than that,
it is the largest
protest in US history.
And it happened this year in
your generation on our watch
and I hope that we
continue to do that work.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to go
to Dr. Kim next,
asking the question
of her, how do we
be intentional about
being intersectional?
And I want to build on
what Linda just laid out.
And if you missed
it, I just want
to hit you with
the bullet points,
you know, at Google, we like the
hit me with the bullet point.
Women of color, I
think what she laid out
is being willing to ask
tough questions to people
in the dominant group, being
willing to educate but not
like necessarily yourself.
Here are some books if
you want to read it.
So you don't sit yourself in
this racial battle fatigue.
You are assertive at
the negotiation table.
She's very clear.
Look, you're not going
to use me as a token.
You're not going to
put my face up there.
We're not going to have
Coca-Cola in the background,
like very assertive in setting
parameters and boundaries
around how are we
going to do this,
rather than being at the
effect of the experience there.
Using the privilege
she does have--
and I think that's really
important to acknowledge
when you're a person of color.
Like we're all walking
around with these identities
of both privilege
and disadvantage.
So she's naming, as a
lighter-skinned Muslim woman,
like what privilege do I
have here that I can center
somebody else's experience?
So thinking about
that as a black woman,
are there people
amongst that community
that I need to be centering?
Because I'm privileged
in a certain way.
I am highly educated at an
elite Ivy League university.
There's definitely room for me
to make space for other women,
other lived experiences,
other frameworks.
And then equalizing,
despite status.
What was the famous
person, I forgot her name.
Was it something--
KIM CRENSHAW:
Scarlett Johansson.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Yes,
It's like you don't
get more talk time
than an undocumented immigrant.
So I mean even thinking about
equalizing on that level.
And I think for white women in
particular, humility, I think,
came up a lot, a
willingness to learn came up
and a willingness to follow,
like regardless of your title,
your position, you fall back.
Somebody else in a
marginalized community
has certain
experiences, which does
create a certain amount
of knowledge that
informs what we should do next.
That's the high
level bullet point.
Dr. Kim we're going to
add to that list of how
do we be intentional.
Add to the list-- how to
be intentional about being
intersectional?
Because there are a lot
of people who are trying
to figure out what to do next.
KIM CRENSHAW: Yeah.
Those are all, I
think, absolutely
essential steps to take.
I think what I would add
to it is an understanding
that the challenge is
to multiple communities,
not just to white women.
So the March was a context
in which the conversation
was about deprivileging
and shifting
the frame to broaden it.
But it's also the
case that that's
a conversation that needs to
be had within institutions.
It's a conversation
that has to be
had within racial
justice struggles.
It's a conversation that has to
be had within LGBTQ struggles.
So in each of these spaces,
the same kind of moves
often have to be made
in order to make sure
that the intersectional
ways that certain kinds
of experiences play
out are actually
at the center of the movement.
This conversation
started with a video clip
from our organization on a
campaign called Say Her Name.
And Say Her Name actually
came out of a march.
We were in a march
in New York City
around the non-indictment of the
officer responsible for killing
Eric Gardner.
There were thousands and
thousands of people there
who had been drawn
because of that injustice.
And in the process
of marching, we
were calling out men who had
been killed by the police.
And there was a whole spate
of them as many of you
know, Michael Brown,
Tamir Rice, Freddie Gray.
We started naming
some of the women who
had been killed
at the same time,
Michelle Cusseaux was killed
within two weeks of Mike Brown,
and no one knew her name.
Ara Russer, Tunisia
Anderson was killed a week
before Tamir Rice, by the
same police department.
No one knew knew her name.
So some part of Say Her Name
is to build on the frame that
already exists.
So we know that
state-sanctioned violence
has been racialized throughout
the history of this country.
We have images.
We have frames.
We have quick ways
of thinking about it.
A lot of people think
in terms of lynching.
They think in terms of
the ways that police
have contributed to that.
But they think of that in
a gender exclusive way.
So our challenge was to take
that frame and broaden it.
To say, everything
you think you know
about state-sanctioned
violence, yes, that's true.
And also this.
So in the same ways
that police have often
said that Mike Brown
was like a monster.
He was framed as someone who
had to be put down with a gun
because he couldn't be stopped.
Actually, police say the
same thing about black women
who are killed.
And when it's said
about a woman,
it's clear that it's a racial
thing that's happening.
There's no way that a woman
could be overtaken and tasered
to death by seven different men
as happened in one of the cases
that we highlight,
tasered to death,
because they said she posed
a risk to their lives.
This is something that's real.
It's something that happened.
It is a real risk
that black women face.
So we try to build
intersectional awareness
based on the single issue
ideas that people have.
If you think this is what
state-sanctioned violence looks
like from a racial
justice point of view,
this is what happens when
you add gender to it.
And it's the same
on the other side.
There is a significant movement
around gender-based violence.
Rape and sexual
abuse is something
that women have organized
around for at least 50 years.
You don't get
women's organizations
organizing around
rape and sexual abuse
by police officers.
But just last year a
police officer in Oklahoma
was convicted for raping and
abusing eight black women.
What made it possible for
him to rape and abuse eight
black women?
It's intersectional
vulnerability.
They're black women,
historically black women
have not been believed.
They were poor women.
Many of them were
system-involved women,
meaning they had
a criminal record.
These were all things that
made this officer believe
that he could do what he
could do with impunity
and nothing was going to happen.
So that's the intersectional
vulnerability.
The problem is neither the
gender-based violence movement,
nor quite honestly, the
anti-racist movement
against police violence
took that case up.
Why is that?
It fell between the cracks.
It fell between, the
way that you think
about race-based violence.
It's shooting, it's
beating, it's not raping.
And it fell between
the way people think
about violence against women.
That's usually seen as
private, not as something
that the state is
responsible for.
So the basic message
is if we want
to think how to
deepen our practice,
we have to ask
concrete questions.
This is the way
gender is imagined
to be a factor in a workplace.
Is it the only way?
Are there other ways that
we can think about it?
Or to flip the script, ,
yes, I'm subject to gender.
But what advantages
do I have that I'm
allowed to use in
order to navigate
this space that another
woman who is not white has?
I'd like to sometimes
think about it
as the difference
between can the boss
imagine you in his
living room or can he
imagine you in the locker room?
So if you're a man
of color, you do
have that racial disadvantage.
But you do have
shared masculinity,
and sometimes you can navigate
your disadvantage with that.
Or if you're a white woman,
yes, gender might be a factor.
But you do have
social similarity.
You do have a common
social cultural history
that you might be able to use.
But that woman of color has
neither of those things.
And if you really want
to have some proof of it,
look at some of the
studies on mentoring.
Mentorship, everyone
knows, is one
of the most significant
things that you can have
to help you navigate upward.
Mentors are most likely to share
some kind of social identity
with their mentees.
So if you can share being a
man or share being a woman,
you're more likely
to be mentored
than if you can't share
either one of those things.
So a practice that says, look,
we know mentorship is good.
But we know it also
doesn't equally
extend across our
entire workforce, that's
a moment for intersectional
intervention.
Those are the kinds of moments
that you can make a difference
by being aware of the
different situation of some
of your workforce.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Thank you.
So now we're going to make a
hard left just a little bit.
And because we're in Texas, and
there were some policy changes
that took place,
was it yesterday,
around the transgender
bathroom policy,
I wanted us to gently
talk about that.
And EJ, I'll start with you,
but anybody else who wants
to hop in on it.
So last May the Department
of Education and Justice
issued joint guidance
directing schools
to let transgender students
use facilities that correspond
with their gender identity based
on the Obama administration's
interpretation of Title
IX, the federal law that
prohibits sex
discrimination in schools
to include gender identity.
Trump's administration rescinded
this guidance yesterday
without offering a replacement.
Supporters of this say that
it's not anti-LGBTQ sentiment,
but federal overreach
into state matters,
and that schools should
be able to determine
this policy at the local level.
I'm curious about what would
be your recommendations, not
just to schools, but
any organization.
Because I think including
our organization
is grappling with
this type of policy.
EJ JOHNSON: Well,
I actually was just
reminded of a story when
I was in high school.
And I remember that we
had our LGBT club fought
for having more gender
neutral bathrooms in school.
And I even remember
talking to my friends
and we were like,
well, who cares?
I mean, like you have your
mens, you have your womens,
and you go to the bathroom.
And now here I am,
being me and doing me,
and realize, OK, like so today
if my outfit requires a skirt,
where do I go?
You know, where
am I comfortable?
I don't have a problem
peeing in the men's bathroom
in whatever outfit I'm in, but
some people do, a lot of people
do.
So I just don't
understand why we wouldn't
have more of those
bathrooms where people
can be comfortable
or at least have
those conversations
or an open environment
where we can at
least talk about it.
And I think that whether
in schools or in offices,
I mean, those are
the types of places
that we need to be having these
conversations about what's
making our community
comfortable,
especially when it's time
to go to the bathroom.
Because everybody has
And so in a school, why do you
want to put some gender fluid
child or someone who doesn't
quite know what they're doing--
but they're doing them, they
don't know where they fit
in yet--
in a situation
where they could get
beat up or ultimately killed?
You never know
what's going down.
Especially in rough
neighborhoods,
when people are
less educated, they
don't know what's going on.
They're very quick to judge.
And they're very quick
to act on those impulses,
just because they see
someone being different.
And I always continue
to think that I'm just
like why would you want
to subject somebody
to that type of
unnecessary violence?
And I'm also grateful that
we're at least having these
conversations, because four
years ago we really weren't.
I was just talking
to you earlier
about the trans community
is having a revolution right
now, which is great.
We weren't really talking
about it before Caitlyn Jenner.
But it's a blessing,
and it's a curse.
Because it opens the door
to have a conversation.
But it also lets in a different
type of discrimination
and a different
type of ignorance.
So I think that we
were making steps
in the right direction
when it comes
to having those bathrooms.
And now that we're taking them
away, and now we have to think,
the states and the
cities have to think
about is this important or not?
I'm like why are we taking
that step back, when we just
made a great stride forward?
LINDA SARSOUR: I
think to your point
about how do you resist any
type of policy, including
bathroom policies?
And this is really the moment
that you think about what
resistance actually looks like.
And when you start taking
matters in your own hand.
This is our country.
These are our schools.
Our taxpayer dollars pay for--
our college campus.
When I think about policies like
sanctuary campuses or sanctuary
workplaces, anything
that this administration
is trying to implement
moving forward
is that, the question is
what are you willing to do?
Is the principle going to find
that resistance in her or him?
Is the corporate CEO going
to say, not on my watch,
not in my company,
whatever that issue is
that's going to be impacted.
And I always tell people,
people will say, you know what?
Now it's the law, whatever.
You know this is just how it is.
And I always tell people
like, that offends me
when people say that.
Because I'm like, oh,
so what you're saying
is if you lived at
the time of slavery,
you would be cool with slavery,
because slavery was law.
If you lived at the
time of segregation,
you were cool with segregation
of races, because you know,
it was the law.
So this idea that in this
country we talk a lot,
and this particular
administration, which
is already showing early
signs of fascism, which
is this obsession
with law and order,
with obsession with
like national security,
you know disdain
for intellectuals
and the arts, like
rampant sexism,
like all the things that we're
seeing from this administration
are clearly fascism.
If you ever went to the
Holocaust Museum in Washington,
DC, there's a sign--
that I didn't write--
that says early warning
signs of fascism.
And literally all these things
I just listed are word for word,
I like memorized them.
So I think that in this
moment that we are in,
and we haven't really been in
it at least in my lifetime,
I mean I know
obviously there has
been many moments of
resistance in the past.
But in my lifetime, I'm 36 years
old, I haven't see a moment,
and I haven't yet even seen it
in the way I want to see it.
This is the time
to be like, I don't
give a damn what policies
come from the top.
I'm ready to protect the people
that are in my communities.
I'm ready to protect
the students that
come to my schools.
I'm going to protect you know
those who come to my church
or my synagogue or my mosque.
You know that this idea that
we have given up so much power
to the law and to the government
that we don't understand
the power that we have.
And that we have to
be willing to say, OK,
you want to come to my church
and take undocumented people,
you got to get through me first.
You want to come to--
we were talking about this,
even with the potential stop
and frisk national law, like
we literally have a Blue Lives
Matter administration.
And notice this,
notice that it's
been a few weeks where
we haven't really
had the trending hashtags about
the black woman or black man
that has been killed
by the police, right?
Does that mean
it's not happening?
It's that we're
so damn distracted
by the outrageousness
that is coming out
of this administration, stuff
that I think we could resist
against, that we forgot
the issues we were already
working on.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Yes, so where
I want to go with this--
is we have a few minutes
left before the Q&A--
is what you just
said there is getting
to a position of realizing
the power that I actually
have, shifting my frame in
terms of my relationship to it,
and [INAUDIBLE] courage.
What I kind of felt
kind of ease up my back
when you were talking through
that is people being like,
I don't really know if I
have that much courage.
I don't even know if I
can walk in that place.
So I'm wondering, like final
words from everybody up here.
I'm keeping it like
20 seconds or less.
Just thinking about how--
TANZINA VEGA: I have
more than 20 seconds.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: --how does one--
you have more--
TANZINA VEGA: Because
I was taking notes.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: How
do we get there?
TANZINA VEGA: I'm a journalist.
OK.
I'm sorry.
I was taking notes.
I wasn't texting, I swear.
OK, so a couple of things,
how do we get there?
One of the things that
I think is critical.
We touched on this a
little bit here and there,
but I want to drive this home.
You have to take
personal responsibility
for understanding the
way this country works,
the way this
country was founded,
the way systems work
and institutions work.
It's my job, right,
literally my job
to explain the systems
of inequity, racism,
and how it gets
played out in America.
That is literally
what I am paid to do.
And I love it and
I will continue
to do it as long as I can.
I recently got an
email from someone.
I wrote a story the
headline was "What
About the Black Working Class?"
Because the narrative we
heard during the campaign
was white working class, white
working class, white working
class, white working
class, right?
Am I wrong?
OK, we left out a whole
segment of the population.
And this is critical.
We are in a moment right now
of absolute necessary media
literacy.
You must understand the
narratives that are being told.
You have to take responsibility.
And learn about as
much as you can.
And then begin to
ask the questions.
So my story about the black
working class comes out.
And I get an email from a reader
who says, look, I'm white.
I'm married.
Live in the Midwest.
My wife and I, we're
screwed by the recession.
How do you explain what you're
trying to say in this piece
and how that affects me?
And I said great.
You want data.
Data you shall have.
And I took 20, 30
minutes out of my day
and crafted an email to
him, very long email,
explaining point by point that
this wasn't about the fact
that whites weren't
affected by the housing
crisis or the great recession.
The fact of the matter
is, if you understand
wealth inequity
in America, there
is a racial wealth
gap where whites
continue to have 13 times the
wealth of blacks and Latinos.
I'm going to put that in
actual figures for you.
$140,000 is the average
wealth for a white family,
$11,000 for black families,
and $13,000 for Latinos.
The math has been done.
These are not typos.
You need to understand
and take responsibility
for learning about how we
got here and why we got here.
That's my job and I'm happy
to answer those questions.
But we're at a point
right now where
we can no longer say I have
no idea what's happening.
I really don't know.
Because you know what,
it's not acceptable.
The other thing I
will say that you
can't put the burden on
marginalized communities
to always explain and
do the work for you.
And there was a book called
"This Bridge Called My Back,"
that analogy right there.
Think about that for a minute.
That's really I think the point.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Thank you.
EJ JOHNSON: I agree with
everything you just said.
That was everything.
But just a little more
I guess on the burden
not being on our
back, but I think
that that's a great point.
At the same time, I
think just with outrage
I think when it comes
to gender and sexuality,
just because it's
such a gray area.
Sometimes we do have to
explain a little more.
And I for instance
do get a bit annoyed.
Well, why doesn't
this person figure out
what's going on in my life?
That I set my rules.
I set my standards.
I know what to call myself.
You don't.
But instead of assuming what
you think I'd like to be called,
you can just ask.
And I'll let you know.
So I think in that
conversation, you
might have to explain
yourself a little bit more.
And that's OK.
Don't get annoyed.
You know it's not them
being annoying or ignorant.
They're just trying to
figure out what's going on.
And we have to take
that part to just
explain a little more
until we get to a place
we don't have to have
these conversations
because everyone is just doing
what they got to be doing.
LINDA SARSOUR: I'm just going
to say just be uncomfortable
and that being
uncomfortable is OK.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: All right.
Time for Q&A.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
on your point of view
as for the pro-life community
not being invited to the March.
I'd just like to hear a
little bit about that.
If you could talk a
LINDA SARSOUR: So that was
another manifested controversy,
so an educational
moment for everyone.
This was a pro-choice march.
So let's say that again.
That means that you
give women the agency
to choose for themselves
whether or not
they want to get an
abortion or whether or not
they want to keep a baby.
So what we were very
clear about from day one
is that this was a
pro-choice march.
So regardless of what your
personal opinion is about that,
you were welcome to the march.
What we were not going
to do is we were not
going to allow specific
anti-choice groups, right?
So there's a difference
between being whoever
you are, and specifically
being against the woman's
right to choose for her body.
Because that is all
types of problematic.
So this was a march that
brought people-- there were
people there who were pro-life.
So as long as you
don't take my right
or want to work against my
right to choose for my own body.
So that was the kind
of context in which
we organized the Women's March.
AUDIENCE: How do we balance
pushing the conversation
deeper, but also keeping a door
open for those who are just
now opening their eyes
and may feel "threatened,"
quote unquote, by talking
about intersectionality?
TANZINA VEGA: I think it
goes back to the point
that I was making.
I don't think anyone has to
walk out of the room saying,
they, too, are
critical race scholars.
Like no one's expecting
that after this chat.
But I do think it's a question
of curiosity and openness
to hearing and being
uncomfortable and asking
the uncomfortable question.
I'm surprised that there's
only one question in the room.
I know there's probably a lot
of questions in people's minds
right now, right, thinking
should I, shouldn't I?
It's OK to ask it.
Like I have these conversations
in the newsroom all the time.
And I'd say I'd rather us have
the uncomfortable conversation
now, behind the scenes, when
we're just trying to figure out
this story or this video, than
broadcast something that's
inaccurate.
KIM CRENSHAW: I want to embrace
the idea of discomfort that
has been put on the
table and normalize
discomfort and denormalize
comfort with injustice.
That's the real shift right now.
I mean we could just take
an example of whatever space
we're in.
I teach at two law schools.
Many times I am the only person
that looks like me in the room
that I'm in.
Never am I in a
room where there's
anywhere close to parity
between people who look like me
and the rest of the population.
I think we're also sitting in
a room where if we were honest,
we would look around
and say there's
a certain lack of parity
between the way this space is
constituted and
the world outside.
It's not unique to Google.
It's everywhere.
And it's on every part of it.
If you go to a family court, or
if you go to a benefit shelter,
that place doesn't look
like the rest of America.
So when we live in a society
when it's still predictable,
by just looking at
someone, whether they're
likely to be the CEO or
the person who cleans,
we still have a hierarchy
that's racially coded.
This is called
decoding race, right?
You're not going to be able
to decode it if you don't know
something needs to be decoded.
It's not something out there.
It's something everywhere
we happen to be.
So the question is,
what kind of orientation
do we want to have as we
began the process of decoding?
Why do we want to decode?
What are the questions
that we want to ask?
I would say that some questions
that we might want to ask
are, what are the societal
processes, the dynamics that
create the space that we're in?
How did it happen?
And what story are
we telling ourselves
if we're not asking
that question?
Because you've got to
have a story about why
your space looks the way it is.
You've got to have a story
about why your neighborhood is
made up the way it is.
You've got to have a story about
why your church looks the way--
you've got to have a story.
You might not be telling
yourself what it is.
But you have a story.
And many times that story
is deeply problematic.
It's often a story about
well, people are just
choosing different things.
Or people just have
different talents,
or they have different
cultural habits.
They have the ability to
withstand instant gratification
is a story.
I mean there are
all sorts of stories
that we tell ourselves about
how our institutions look
the way they do.
And when we don't
challenge those stories,
we reproduce those systems.
Because we tend to reproduce the
same thing that got us there.
When you're asking what
should the next CEO look like,
or what should be a
qualification for doing x job,
you're likely to base the answer
on what the system has already
produced.
But what that
system has produced
didn't come out of nowhere.
It wasn't something
that just got
constituted without race and
without gender playing a role.
So by saying discomfort, I mean
being uncomfortable not asking
those questions-- being
uncomfortable just going along
like it's all OK, being brave
enough to say it's up to us
to decide how much of this
we can produce differently.
How we can be creative about
how we conceptualize what
a good candidate is,
to be creative enough
to think about how this job
could be done differently,
to be bold enough to
say we're not satisfied
with our society
looking the way it does,
or this institution
looking the way it does.
It's those kind of
discomforts that I
think we should want to create.
And we should want to be
uncomfortable with not
doing that.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Deep
inquiry and reflection.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So if I think about
what the many policies that
bother me about the
new administration,
it's the education,
school choice,
and how that's going to impact
women of color in particular.
So I just want to hear your
thoughts on what we can do,
what you think that
impact could be,
and how we can change
that trajectory possibly.
KIM CRENSHAW: Well, I'll
start with just a couple
of observations
I'm sure everyone
has some thoughts about this.
So I'm going to say a word
that gets talked about a lot,
but isn't often defined.
We're in a neoliberal moment.
By that I'm trying to capture
the idea that everything
is being reduced to markets.
And in that, most things
are being privatized, which
includes public education.
So the moves that we're going
to be seeing in public education
and in health and in
pretty much everything else
are moves to greater and
greater privatization.
With greater
privatization, typically
has become greater
levels of inequality,
greater levels of
hierarchy, greater levels
of people of color
particularly not being
able to make it to the top.
So I think that we can more
or less predict the areas that
will be more likely impactful
on communities of color
are those areas
where people of color
actually had a greater role
in the public production
of the good.
Education is one of them.
Government in general
is another one.
Why is it that people of color
actually are more in government
than other places?
Well, let's start
asking those questions.
I think there are
clear answers to that,
and consequently there are
clear answers to the outcome.
I'll say this as
just a last point.
Because I think
the tendency when
people hear why are certain
institutions looking
the way they do, including
the government, which
is far more integrated
than private space,
there is a sense that that's
the product of discrimination
that happened a long time ago.
I don't think there is a sense
that there are things happening
right here and right now.
They might not look
like the kind of things
that we are used to before.
There aren't white only signs.
People aren't picketing.
They're not throwing bricks
at Martin Luther King.
But there are other ways in
which pipelines are racially
constructed, so that, yes, more
people are in public education
than private.
Yes, more people are in
certain jobs than others.
And then here's the last
thing, yes, more people
have wealth than others.
So Tanzina was talking
about the wealth gap.
Let me add this last piece.
Women of color have a median net
worth, Latinas and black women,
of $0.
I just want you to think
about what that means.
Close to a majority
of women of color
don't have the amount of wealth
that it takes to buy a Big Mac.
I mean wealth is what you have
after all of your deficits,
all your debts are
subtracted from your assets.
Wealth is what allows you to
provide for your children.
take care of a sick parent
and also send your
kid to summer camp.
Wealth is what allows
you to move to a place
where you can have
access to healthy food
or you can have
access to recreation.
Wealth is the thing that
allows you to actually sustain
yourself during
the kind of crises
that will always be happening
in an economy like ours.
When we can say that one
part of our population
has a median net
wealth of zero it's
telling you that the pipelines
that their children will be in
are not going to lead
to places like this.
So it's going all the way
back to the baselines,
who has what in this society,
and that's not natural.
So maybe you know,
maybe you don't--
at a time when the
government played the biggest
role in creating
the neighborhoods
we have was in the federal
housing, the creation
of federal housing.
They spent $120 billion,
these are in 1940s dollars,
to create suburbs.
These suburbs were created
as all white enclaves
by the government.
So what does it mean to have
bought a house in the suburbs
in 1940, for let's say,
$25,000 versus being forced
to live in a ghetto for about
the same amount in terms
of your monthly housing costs?
That gave you a difference
between having a house back
then and an apartment.
But now, three
generations later,
the one who bought the house?
What are they able to
do with that equity?
They can send kids to college.
They can send kids
to graduate school.
You can go around the
world if you want to.
The family that had to
settle for the apartment
in the ghetto, probably
still is living
in an apartment in a ghetto.
We'll look at that
and say, well, those
are just natural realities.
They are the product
of public policy,
so the point is,
if public policy
can create racialized class,
then it can uncreate it.
We just have to be willing
to see that these are
the products of public policy.
That's the challenge
that I'm trying
to encourage everybody to do.
TANZINA VEGA: And I want you to
think on an individual level,
too.
Yeah, please.
[APPLAUSE]
I mentioned before I grew
up in public housing.
I also went to public school.
I have a master's degree.
I have an undergraduate degree.
And those are all
from public school.
And why is that the case?
Because it was a
financial decision.
You wouldn't think that
because of where I work
and like I said,
the big fancy job.
And I hope you like my
outfit, things like that.
But the fact of the matter is
growing up in that environment,
without having that
equity to pass on,
it doesn't only afford
you those opportunities,
it means I can't take a break.
It's very hard to take a break.
I want you guys to understand
when you're looking at resumes,
because this comes up a lot,
especially when you're thinking
we've got to hire brown people.
Right?
We've got to hire
these brown people.
So you're looking at
all the brown people
that work in your department.
And you're like, they've
got to know somebody, right?
And then you get all the resumes
in, and then the first thing
you do, and I know you all
do this is look for what?
Harvard, Stanford,
yada, yada, we're
going to go on and on, right?
But do you look at
state university?
Uh uh.
That's out.
That's in the circular
file immediately, right?
Right there you're
eliminating a talent pool
that you haven't
even considered.
And there's nothing
wrong with Harvard
and Stanford and Columbia and
all these wonderful places.
I'll be potentially
teaching at some
of those places in my future.
So the fact of the matter is
these are amazing institutions,
but we cannot
continue to assume,
especially when you're
looking for talent of color,
you're only looking
for the unicorn.
The unicorns are
amazing but unicorns
live in many different
parts of this population.
I guarantee you that
you get somebody who's
worked so hard to get there.
And to them getting a job at
Google or at "The New York
Times" or one of these
places, it's like--
I mean it's unthinkable.
You're creating a
pathway to prosperity.
You're creating a change
in someone's class level
potentially.
And that's not to say that it's
magic, and all of a sudden.
Because I have that
fancy job, and I'm not,
my net worth isn't like--
believe me I'm still
shopping discount.
But the point is
that that matters.
And you all, again, bringing
it back to yourselves,
really take a look at when
you're examining people.
Because that's a big
part of, I think,
where we tend to block a
black person or Latino person,
but only if they went to
da, da, da, da, da place.
It eliminates too many people.
AUDIENCE: It seems like the
media is attending to whatever
is the most important to
the most people at that
time, which leads to a very
reactionary type of response
from everyone.
How do we avoid that?
How do we be more proactive and
avoid this sort of firefighting
mentality where we're
only attacking the issues
that Twitter cares about?
TANZINA VEGA: Thank
you for that question.
I'm assuming you
wanted me to answer it
as a member of the media,
the mainstream media.
Woo!
All right, I tell people I
was just on a panel a week ago
for this talk on
race and policing.
And a similar
question was raised.
And I said you, as
media consumers,
have a tremendous
amount of power.
I'll give you the example.
At "The New York Times," I
created the race beat in 2013.
I said, went to the then
executive editor Jill Abramson,
and said, look,
I've got this idea.
I think these stories
are doing well.
This is pre-Ferguson, just
so we have a timeline.
So, oh, yeah, this
is a great idea.
Let's do it.
I said great.
I went from doing what I
was doing on the media desk
to covering this beat.
And I think I was
the first Latina
to found a beat like
that at "The Times."
Not to say "The Times" hadn't
covered race in the past,
it had.
But it had been about 13 years
since they did it systemically.
And so I was suggesting that
we sit down and have me do it
and kick it off, and that
I think went very well.
We had a lot of great stories.
You can look them
up yourselves look
I've covered everything from
black women and discipline
in schools to Asian-American
elder care issues to how
Arab-Americans and Latino
Americans are answering
the census form, like
who's white, who's not.
I mean we sort of went all over.
And these stories got
really good responses.
After about a year,
"The Times" decided
we don't need this beat,
for whatever reason,
and we're killing it.
What they didn't realize,
and what I told them was,
this isn't going to sit
well with our audience.
Well, guess what?
It didn't.
The audience took to Twitter.
We had a public
editor at "The Times,"
an ombudsman at "The Times."
At that time, it was
Margaret Sullivan, who's
now at "The Washington Post."
And just email, just
people were just like done.
Like they were like, what
are you talking about?
And it just became this huge
issue where the public editor
called and said, look, I've got
to cover this for "The Times."
So that's not awkward, right,
I'm working at the company,
but now I'm going to be the
subject of an internal public--
not a review, but
really it's essentially
an answer to our public.
That's what the ombudsman is
for to say, wait, everybody's
upset.
Let's interview and hold this
institution's feet to the fire.
At the center of that,
totally cool, not a problem.
It was very difficult
to see that,
but it was also really
heartening to show that wow,
we get results.
Your readers can get results.
It was covered in
"Columbia Journalism
Review," NPR, "National Review,"
I mean all these places--
I'm sorry.
"The New Republic,"
not "National Review."
That would have been
a whole other story.
So we got a lot of
coverage about this issue.
And I wasn't being interviewed.
It was just about
the issue at large.
So long story short,
they brought it back.
I left, but they
brought it back.
And now they're attempting
in their own way
to try and cover
race in America.
I wish them the best.
But I look at that
as an opportunity.
And it was really interesting
to see the audience say, wait
a minute.
This is not what we want.
So you guys have a
tremendous amount of power.
You also are inundated
with media left and right
from every corner of
the world at this point.
I'm considering taking
Twitter off my phone,
because I just can't.
And I have to do
this for a living.
You have to pay attention
to the people who
are writing the content
or shooting the content
or making the content that
you want to see and support
that content, whether it
means subscribing, watching,
clicking, e-mailing, sending
a letter to the editor,
or whatever it is.
Because ultimately that's
how you change the narrative.
That's the work
I'm trying to do.
It was shut down at one place.
I brought it someplace else.
And said all right, maybe
it won't be shut down here.
But I'm just one of x thousands
and thousands of voices
out there.
So I try to do my part
and elevate my stories
and signal boost my stories
to get out there and try
to tell these narratives
that aren't getting told.
And there are many other people
that are trying to do the same,
but they need to be supported.
LINDA SARSOUR: So
I think sometimes
we're asked to do either-or.
I think we do kind of
still have to be prepared
to do rapid response in crisis.
Like people always
say to me, why
are you always outraged
when black people
are killed by the police?
Like that's just how it is.
And I say to people,
look, it is how it is.
It's been how it is.
But I want to be outraged.
And don't take my
humanity away from me
and tell me that I
shouldn't be outraged
every time a black person is
killed at the hands of law
enforcement.
So what Twitter has
done, it has its benefits
in that it allows me, sitting
in Brooklyn, New York,
to figure out that there
is a young man named
Mike Brown in Ferguson that just
got shot by a police officer.
It allows me to be connected
to those very human stories
that if we as a
society don't elevate,
ain't nobody care
about Mike Brown.
Nobody cares about Sandra Bland.
So it really is props to the
young people who figured out
to take a public platform
to basically be able to say
you will not ignore our pain.
You will not ignore the blood
on the streets in our community.
So there is that
opportunity to just
be able to say, yes,
maybe Sandra Bland
was a trending hashtag.
Praise the Lord that it was.
Because I would have
never learned her story.
I would have never been
able to say her name.
But to the other parallel
that we could use,
I'm always in crisis response.
Like I'm always ready
to do rapid response.
But I also understand
the importance
of building longevity and
building sustainability
in our communities.
So while we're not
organizing for Sandra Bland,
how are we preventing
another black woman
from getting shot
by a police officer
or being killed in a cell
in custody of our state,
basically.
And I think what we
often do is we get--
and this is why I
always say to people,
ain't no time for
part-time progressives,
part-time activists.
You're either coming in
here to invest your time
or you get out of
our way, because I
don't want to see you, right,
at that protest that one time.
I'm not saying that that's
not beneficial to show up.
But I want to know
where you are tomorrow,
and the day after that.
Because when you leave
here, there's still
someone else that's impacted.
That person has not
come back to life.
And oftentimes those very
people that we protest for still
don't get justice.
Everybody-- you can name any
trending hashtag in the past
year and a half--
not one of those
people got justice.
So we didn't even win
those smaller fights.
So being able to organize,
being able to give resources
to the very local organizations
on the ground in places
like Ferguson, being
able to say, OK,
who's in Texas organizing
around Sandra Bland.
What kind of resources
do those people need?
How can I as a Googler
be able to provide?
Maybe I can't do it in
my official capacity,
but I may be an engineer.
I may know how to build
a website for them.
I may know how to help
them fix their algorithm so
that whatever story they got
is going out even farther.
We all got something to
give to the movement.
So for me, it's
like yes, show up.
Yes, be outraged.
It's OK that there's
a trending hashtag.
The question is,
what are you offering
so that next time,
god forbid, there
is to be something that
happens in that community,
they got more resources
than they had six months ago
when another person went
down in their community.
So I think for me, it's like
we could stay rapid response
and crisis response.
And we, by the way, are going
to have to do a lot of that
under this administration.
Just letting y'all
know, get ready.
I'm already tired.
It's only been in
like five weeks.
But really understanding,
like communities of color,
we just are always
like, oh, man.
We're just being
hit from every way,
and we never just get
the time to be left.
We would like to reflect
and have a retreat
and figure out how to do asset
mapping and what we need.
And we try that, we attempt it.
The minute we leave
that retreat on Monday,
someone else is shot
in our community,
a family is about
to be deported,
a mosque is vandalized,
this one gets--
we just are always distracted.
So the question for us is how
do we build sustainability,
and then how do our
white allies, who
aren't easily distracted
because they don't have
the same priorities or they're
not as directly impacted as we
are, which was why the
Women's March on Washington
was as successful as it is.
I'll give you an example.
A lot of the people
that did the--
so for example, graphic
designer was like, we coming in.
We're going to do your branding.
I didn't have to ask.
I was like just, I would
have just slapped anything.
I don't even care.
The website, the
social media, people
who were like, we got you.
You do the work.
You set the policy agenda.
You do the outreach,
you call the partners,
you do what you're good at.
We'll do all that other
technological-- whatever.
And a lot of these people
do work at tech firms.
And that's why we had
such a big apparatus.
And people were like, where did
they get those resources from?
It cost us zero.
It was people who own
tech firms and said
this is what we want to do.
This is what we want
to offer the movement.
And by the way,
those same people
didn't bounce on January 21st.
Those people are still
maintaining the infrastructure,
hosting our website, making sure
that our stuff is maintained,
that it's still up today.
So think about
being able to say,
it's OK to be doing rapid
response and crisis response,
but how do we think about
longevity, sustainability,
and building a movement
that lives outside of us
and lives beyond every
individual case of outrage
that we are in
almost on a daily.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: All right.
So let's thank our
panelists first.
[APPLAUSE]
And because this
is Google, I know
some takeaways I just
want to land with.
I tried to summarize some of the
points that you all laid out.
And I think you're
wondering what can I
walk out of here with.
I think the first
piece of advice
is the current status quo
that we have right now,
to not see it as normal.
So if you are
working in staffing,
if you're working in
any type of organization
where you're taking
a look at diversity,
if you're taking a
look at whether or not
this place is inclusive,
the way things
exist right now is
something that was created.
And it was created by
the people in the room,
in the office, not some external
arm or some force outside of us
that's being created.
So I think Dr. Crenshaw
invited us to say,
let's look at
what's here, what we
see as normal, as
our day to day,
and it's not something
that's normal.
It's not something
that's out of my hands.
And so engage in that
deep inquiry process
of how is this created now.
And then think about what
is my responsibility,
I think was said a
few times up here.
The second thing is to
develop an awareness
of our own personal
power, so this
sense that this is too
big for me to handle.
I think we have great
examples of people who are all
engaged in the work,
put their talent
and their creativity
combined together
to begin to disrupt things.
Great examples of
that happening here.
And you're human, just
as they're human, right?
And what they can
do, you can do.
The third thing is
actually, instead
of asking the question of what
about me, when someone starts
centering their experience,
to ask the question
what can I offer?
And really asking the
question of who around me
is encountering multiple
forms of violence,
multiple forms of
disadvantage, and it
doesn't matter what your
identity is, but actually think
about that.
Particularly when we're
centering an issue that makes
you personally uncomfortable.
I just want to drive
that point home.
If it makes you
uncomfortable, it's
probably the issue we
need to be talking about.
And then finally, I love this
last talk about infrastructure.
So I know that people
are trying to figure out,
given what their roles are,
particularly if they're
technical in nature, or they
don't see the direct connection
to it, really thinking about
what's my talent, what's
my gift, what's my skill?
And how can I lend it to
whatever the causes the issue
is?
And notice, she didn't
describe somebody
going there and asking for it.
She described
people who offered.
And so really be
thinking about how do I
step up in offering my talent
and gifts to this position.
All right.
Thank you all for your time.
Thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]